draconian bills to restrict self-defense
rights have a life of their own in
Congress there's always one lurking in
the background left to its own devices
it's unlikely to become law but it's
ready to be deployed if a suitable
high-profile crime or a convenient
crisis emerges to ease its passage and
that brings us to the gun violence
prevention and Community Safety Act of
2020 a far-reaching bill hovering in the
legislative shadows as the Cova 19
pandemic breaks down barriers to
authoritarian measures introduced in the
Senate and the house at the end of
January by senator Elizabeth Warren of
Massachusetts and representative Hank
Johnson of Georgia the bill would impose
federal licensing for guns and
ammunition require universal background
checks ban so-called assault weapons
outlaw normal capacity magazines
regulate DIY firearms and otherwise
imposed the full wish list of
restrictions sought by those who would
prefer to see an armed government ruling
over disarmed citizens with its massive
intrusions into rights cherished by much
of the population the proposed law is a
recipe for massive non-compliance
confrontations between people and
enforcers and deepened political
divisions it's also exactly the sort of
legislation that is normally dead on
arrival but these aren't normal times
officials with fever dreams of expanded
power thrive on our fear as the corona
virus pandemic brings the world to a
juddering halt an anxious citizens
demand action leaders across the globe
are invoking executive powers and
seizing virtually dictatorial Authority
with scant resistance
the New York Times warned on March 30th
the restrictions described in the
article are wide-ranging covering
everything from detaining people to
surveillance the censorship of speech
aimed at politicians and their policies
the Department of Justice has floated
the idea of indefinite detention
California governor Gavin Newsom
speculated about the possibility of
martial law if we feel the necessity
Washington DC's mayor Muriel Bowser
wants to arrest anybody who ventures
from home for an unapproved reason and
jurisdictions across the country have
ordered or considered ordering gun
stores along with other non-essential
businesses closed for the duration of
the crisis in selling their gun bill
Warren and Johnson play on the fears of
many members of the public
and their desire to be saved from unseen
perils in a joint January 30th press
release trumpeting their gun bill Warren
and Johnson described a country rife
with violence in homes and on sidewalks
in schools and supermarkets in places of
worship and workplaces it invoked fear
of a false crisis involving a made-up
epidemic just as a real crisis sized
epidemic was rolling into our lives that
potent combination of real and overblown
crises doesn't mean that the gun
violence prevention and Community Safety
Act of 2020 will pass but it does mean
that this is a ripe moment for
authoritarian laws and practices of all
sorts it also means that this particular
legislative monstrosity is being sold in
precisely the most effective way for
such a moment and pushback is an
important just for self-defense rights
it's a necessary part of a larger effort
to put government's on notice they must
stop exploiting our fear to expand their
power
[Music]